- It's free organic reach.
I don't know what else to tell you.
You post something and
80,000 people might see it.
This portion is like with me,
so I think this is when
you need to get selfish.
Like you need to ask your question.
(upbeat music)
Hiring is guessing, firing is knowing.
Like, you gotta fast.
That's how you get shit done,
that's how you figure stuff out.
This is the television and
the television is the radio.
So forties motherfuckers.
So everybody, how's it going so far?
How's the day been going.
- Great.
- Going good.
- Great, yeah.
- Fantastic.
- Solid.
- Great, alright,
so why don't we go around, Joe,
maybe you'll call on people,
- Yep.
- and what we're doing here is going kind
of in-depth consulting.
So we'd love to spend one minute on,
you know, who you are,
and you know, and a
little bit about yourself,
and then I'll go back around
and I want you to think
about the very direct question you have,
'cause I want to go very narrow,
and so it's great to see all of you,
it's great to see some faces, Calvin,
it's good to see your face again.
I haven't seen you in awhile.
Great to see that, nice to see you.
- Likewise man.
- And let's go
through it Joe,
lead us the way.
- Yep.
Sure, let's go to Yasmeen,
she's over in Dubai,
I'm going to kind of work my way.
- Oh, I'm the first one?
Okay.
- Hi Yasmeen.
- Hi Gary, what's up?
- All good.
- So I'm an entrepreneur.
I have a business in
Switzerland, in Zurich,
that's a salon, we specialize in eyebrows,
and I'm currently here in Dubai
building the second salon.
And it's been a challenge,
but I am doing it.
- Because of COVID?
- Yes, of course.
Of course.
- Yes.
- Yes, it's postponed for so long
and I had a lot of fears
and all that stuff,
but I'm doing it anyways
because this will stop at one point.
So yeah.
- Correct.
- And Dubai is looking
very well in terms of 2021,
the expo and everything,
so it will be a boom at one point,
and that's what I'm currently doing.
But in the COVID time, my e-commerce site
was built because I realized, okay,
if I don't have services,
I'm making minus,
not just zero.
- Correct.
- So I built up an e-commerce
store with brow products
and it's been amazing,
people were going crazy over it,
we made like 20K from launching
just for a few days just to test it.
- Amazing.
- And it was quite good,
and now I'm working on that and my,
should go with the question?
- No, I'm going to get a context,
and then we'll go back for questions.
- Okay.
- So thank you,
- Okay, great.
- Good job.
- Let's move over to
Matt Henry down under,
the packaging king of Australia,
Matt say hi to Gary.
- Good day Gary, how's it going?
I've never been called that Joe.
So yeah, Gary, I'm looking after,
essentially I'm the GM of the business,
but I'm really a traditional CMO.
So I'm on the exec team looking
after a team of about 75,
and packaging business,
we do about five other categories as well,
but with my well-known packaging
and that's the leading category,
doing about a hundred
mil a year in revenue
with about 40,000 customers.
It's predominantly B2B,
but it's shifting super,
super rapidly to, you know,
B2B2C, there's some B2C as well.
- It's a hybrid, back to your point,
the first intro was a
perfect example, right?
Humans are building up companies at scale
that are going to need packaging,
and so those businesses
are emerging quickly.
It makes a ton of sense,
I'm seeing this dynamic
with packaging in the US.
- Right, yeah,
so, I mean, we've gone from,
you know, our customers being
like Coke and Ikea to now,
you know, we now can build
a huge amount of scale with,
you know another 30,000
small customers from,
you know, jewelers.
- And by the way,
those customers are going
to grow in perpetuity.
- For sure, yeah,
so that's were see our growth.
- That's where the Internet's taking us,
so I understand so.
- Cool.
- That's the business,
so, okay.
- Okay, let's.
- Real pleasure, cheers.
- Let's go to the Western
side of the United States
and talk to one of my favorite categories
of the automotive category,
Josh Letsis is an auto
dealer in the Colorado area.
Josh, say hi Gary.
You're on mute Josh.
- Josh,
you're on mute, brother.
- Rookie mistake,
- No worries.
- Gary, I actually met you at Agent 2021
a couple of years ago,
so good to see you again,
- Good to see you.
- but yeah, I'm a part owner
in three automotive dealerships
just outside of Denver, Colorado.
- And I mean, that's really ultimately
all the context I need,
but just to give me a little more fodder,
since that was so quick,
What was your biggest
ambition coming to this?
Like what do you hope to get out of this?
- Yeah, so we've created
kind of a character
that's a caricature of myself
and old school car dealers
that were running where I've
got this cheesy plaid suit
and it's introducing, you know, humor,
and then also a lot of
like value adds like,
you know, hey, how do I
change my wiper blades?
Why should I lease versus purchase?
A lot of value adds.
- Two
of my favorite maneuvers in business.
- Yeah, so those are two things
that we're doing right now.
And I just want to figure out
how can we expand on that?
We bought the stores in August
and so we're starting at zero.
- You got it, okay.
- Next we're going
to go over to Texas and say hi
to Sam Rodriguez was in the
financial services business
as an advisor.
Sam, say hi to Gary.
- Hey Gary, how's it going man?
- Really well, Sam.
- Ah, yeah.
So I'm a financial planner,
I run a small team of
advisors here in North Texas,
and I'm really just
trying to take advantage
of what's going on now and
move my industry sort of
into this new age of how to reach people.
- So you're looking to
build personal brand,
let's say, on a LinkedIn
strategy to acquire clients
and have leverage to
acquire even teammates,
and help your teammates be better as well?
- That's exactly right.
Right, like I really want
to attract those clients
and attract advisors that
want to help those clients.
- I understand.
Keep it going, awesome.
- Oklahoma, just north of him,
we've got Brad Dery,
Who's an agency owner,
so very similar to what you started
- Yep.
- back in 2009, Gary.
Say hi to Gary, Brad.
- Hey Gary, yeah,
so next month will be 10 years old.
Until 2018, it was really just
kind of paying side hustle,
maybe a little more than a side hustle,
2018, we kind of launched off
it became a lot more than a side hustle.
- What were you doing besides that, Brad?
- Ministry, actually,
I was a pastor for like
almost 10 years again,
- That's amazing,
good for you.
Keep going.
- 2018 we launched off
and really entered the home
services niche pretty heavily.
So we worked mostly
with contractors, APAC,
speak back plumbing, that kind of thing.
- Yep.
- All across the country,
yeah.
- Know it well.
Okay, great,
looking forward to your questions.
- Continue up north and we'll
head over to Vance in Chicago
who's a motivational speaker/author.
- I know that game.
- Vance, say hi to Gary.
- Vance what's good?
- Hey, what's up man?
Good to see you.
My name is Vance Stanton,
I'm a author of this book,
"Make It Your Season",
I can't see myself,
so also, yeah,
I'm a author and I've studied some
of the greats in motivational speaking
for example Napoleon Hill
and things like that,
so I'm upcoming just like, you know,
trying to get where you are,
and I also wrote a book
about you that I want
to share with you today.
- Okay, can't wait to hear about it.
That's great.
So you're just trying to build more brand
to have leverage for speaking and books.
- Exactly.
- So be very ready for that.
Okay?
- Thank you.
- And last but not least
closer to home, Gary,
over in BK, we've got Calvin who you know,
and have had dinner with in past.
Calvin, say hi to Gary again.
- Hey Gary, great to meet you again.
- Great to see you
again Calv, what's good?
- Yeah, lots of things.
- Good.
- So yeah, I have a software company,
Simplero, I've had that for 11,
we actually just talked
about it in the past,
and already looking to build my personal,
because I want then
expand into some other,
I'm passionate about purpose, meaning,
like knowing who you are,
how that fits into your
business relationships,
health, so I'm doing a meal replacement
and a workout product,
and then I have ideas for
all kinds of other things,
ultimately wanting to be a
special advisor to the president
of the United States at
some point in the future,
helping bring the country back together.
- Very cool, understood.
- One thing real quick, Gary,
before we go into the
second round and go deeper,
just wanted to acknowledge
that there are some folks
here that brought their
plus ones with them,
I have, I'll start off
Courtney Bridgewater Nelson's
my newest resident on the West Coast.
- Hey Courtney.
- So if there's
any people on the phone that would like to
introduce their plus ones really quick
before we go into the deep
dive, feel free to do so now.
- I'll go, I brought Jay Croft,
my social media manager, social media guy,
he's the one person on
team get Calvin right now,
I had like five, six last year,
but it didn't quite work
out, so we're down to Jay.
- One step backwards is
always a good strategy.
- Right, and I have Danielle
here who is in Canada,
she is my executive assistant
and in charge of hiring and culture.
- Amazing.
- Folks,
slow down my line to be here.
- Thanks Jay, I appreciate it brother,
thanks for the love.
I saw you take the photo
and I was fired up,
I'm always flattered by that shit.
- I also forgot to mention
we do have Kate from our Tennessee office.
- Yes, I saw the name,
I wasn't sure if she was
running around the house,
or why she's not showing
her video, but I was,
there you are Kate. (chuckles)
- Okay, cool, so let's go back around
in that same.
- And James Orsini.
Who I see is there.
- Yes, James is here.
- Okay, cool,
let's back around the horns,
same pattern, this way we can go quickly.
- Yip, so starting with
Yasmeen over in Dubai,
Yasmeen, what do you want
to talk to Gary about today?
- Okay, so what came clear to me today
is the personal brand,
my fear there was, which I
asked the question already,
my fear was okay if I
build a personal brand that
is so attached to my business,
how do I exit with it being
emotionally attached to me?
Is it, then not?
- You'll be stuck working
for your new company that
bought you for three years,
and after that, you'll be free as a bird,
and you'll do it again.
- Oh, okay.
No, but I've asked that question
and now I feel better
about it.
- But it's a very,
yeah, it's a very interesting question,
I'm glad you asked it.
A lot of people fear,
so it stops them from
building a personal brand,
which oftentimes, not always,
often is the biggest leverage point
you have to building a big business,
but look at the history of time,
but even closer to your
world, Bobby Brown,
the incredible makeup
artist, she sold her company.
She worked for Revlon, or L'Oreal,
or Estee Lauder, I don't remember
which big company bought
her, for several years,
non-compete, and then she moved on.
I'm currently living this right now,
I started a wine brand,
I sold it to Constellation in March,
I'm tied up for another three years,
and then after three years
I'm going to start a tequila brand,
or another wine brand, or what,
or nothing.
So I think you need.
- That was my biggest fear,
and I've looked at it in
the wrong perspective.
- Correct.
- But my biggest question
for you is if you would
be in my shoes right now
building two different businesses,
they feel like two different businesses,
although the same brand, right?
What would your strategy
be there if you were me?
- I would think about the
world in a 60, 20, 20 realm.
60, 20, 20, all of my behavior,
the way I would staff, my brain,
my heart, the way I would
think about the world,
would be 60, 20, 20.
Let me explain.
60% of my energy, time, money
would be around the brand,
because to your point,
it's the same brand,
two different functions.
- Yes.
- 20% of my heart,
my soul, my money, my energy
would be for the unique
individual businesses
to stand up their needs.
So obviously the salon
that people come to.
- Okay, what do you mean with that?
- You've got, correct me if I'm wrong,
you've got the salon
and then you're selling the
product direct to consumer.
- Yes.
- So spending time to hire
a manager for the salon,
thinking about the
aesthetics of the salon,
renovating the salon,
changing the prices of how
much you charge at the salon,
that gets 20% of my
energy, it really gets 80,
because the 60% up top
is I'm always thinking
about my business and my brand.
- Yeah.
- Same on the other side,
having a meeting around
cardboard with Matt
or packaging is not
something the salon needs,
but it's something your DTC business does.
What I'm giving you as a triangle
to think about your day, why that works
is then you don't get too
far away from one side
or the other, because you've
got to carry both balls.
Understand?
- Hmm.
- So that's how I would think about it.
They're different businesses,
but they're all one business.
- Yeah.
- It's like having two children.
- Yeah, it feels that way.
- Right, but they're both your family,
they're both your children,
you're going to care
equally and passionately,
and if anybody, you know,
some of the people here are further along
in their parenting lives,
sometimes one child needs
a lot more attention
for 36 months, then another
one for a week than it,
and so being mentally prepared to bounce
between where you need to be is important.
But I think what you
have is exactly right.
I think you've structured it properly.
I think in today's world, having a DTC
and a physical component
is a very smart strategy.
I, for example, as you've been noticing,
I've been sipping on something,
this is called bone broth,
I am obsessed with it.
I am seriously thinking
about, not kidding,
getting into the bone broth business.
- Good move.
- And when I think about it,
I think about having a
incredible, beautiful location,
one, in New York, one in LA,
one in Austin, one in Miami,
one in Chicago, right,
one in Denver,
and then a very aggressive
refrigerated direct
to consumer business.
So, you know, I think you do both
in today's world of
internet and real life.
You should be in both, if you're capable,
some people are not,
but I like the way you're going about it.
- That's great.
What would you say, if you say,
let's say 60% is brand energy
and 20% into the salons, right?
What would you?
- Don't forget,
60% brand is really 80% of the salon,
'cause the 60% is really for both.
You know, it's just
always think about brand,
you know, when I say 60,
it's kind of like the 60
is then being deployed
against the salon, the
60 is deployed against
the direct consumer business,
and both are getting 20%
of their unabated time,
so really you're doing 80 and 80.
- Okay.
- So it's not like
you're just sitting thinking about brand,
every day, you're either in one side
or the other operating your business.
- Hmm.
- And probably every day
a little bit of both, just like me.
- Yeah.
- Sometimes
I'm in VaynerMedia,
right now I'm spending an hour
and a half on Sasha Group.
I have a very capable leader in James,
and he has a very capable team
around him, as you can tell,
so I don't have to spend
a lot of time on it,
you know, this is mainly a company,
Sasha is basically a whole bunch of OGs,
Kate's been with us for
six, or five at this point,
or four, right Kate?
Like this is an OG team, mainly
because I'm scared shitless
for small businesses to lose
because a big company losing a million
is very, five and a half,
thanks Kate, is very, by the way,
I'm pretty proud of myself
of saying six and five first,
which pretty much nailed it,
so just saying, that's an example
of being in your business.
The fact I have 1500 or 1200 employees,
but I really did guess
six and five for Kate,
and it ends up being five and a half,
that means you're in your business,
but you know how to scale.
I know how long Kate's been here,
I know about her, but
I don't need to speak
to her every day,
and especially because she's
at five and a half year amrk,
I know what the conversations
we had in the first year
in Chattanooga, I also know
who's around in this company,
it's mainly OGs,
that allows me not to spend as much time.
You might move from 60, 20, 20
to 65 and 35, excuse me,
because you know the person
running your DTC is perfect,
you got the system, you don't
have to put your energy there,
but the salon, your best
person left and you've got it,
and so you're always moving,
but that's the way you think about it.
- Hmm.
In terms of marketing, like right now,
I have somebody that's going to do my ads.
- The number one thing I want to tell you,
'cause I'm in the Dubai market,
I've multiple people in Dubai right now,
we're doing a lot more stuff in Dubai,
you have to get serious
about TikTok yesterday.
- Yes, I wrote that down.
- Yesterday.
Like starting tomorrow,
three posts a day on
TikTok, starting tomorrow,
if you can.
- Yeah, we'll do that.
- And the paid person, make
80% of the energy show you
that they're getting sales on DTC
and getting registration at the salon,
and 20% just attention
for the overall brand.
- So, can you repeat that?
- I can, when you give her or him the job,
and you give them money, say,
look, show me each month or each quarter,
or however you do it,
that the money we spent
led to a sale on the.com
or a reservation at the salon
for 80 cents out of
every dollar I give you.
So if I give you a
hundred thousand dollars,
show me what the $80,000
that it drove business,
the other 20,000 you can spend
on building up the brand.
- Okay, no I got it.
- Cool
- Thanks Gary.
- You got it.
Joe?
- We're going to switch gears,
go and talk about cars,
let's talk to Josh over in Colorado.
Josh, really intrigued by
the alter ego you've created,
let's get into it.
- Yeah, so we bought the
dealerships August 3rd,
and this is all I've
ever done is automotive,
so it's definitely.
- But you've never
owned dealerships before, or you have?
- I have, so I was a partner
with Elway in a Chevrolet store,
I took a couple of years off
did some consulting and then got back.
Yeah.
- And now you're back?
- Yeah, it's in my blood,
can't get out.
- Love it.
- So we created
this alter ego, like I said,
his name is Chuck Cheatham
and he has this nasty.
- I'm so pumped Josh, this is brilliant,
you now that, right?
- Yeah.
So he's got this nasty suit
that ironically I found
on Etsy and fits me like a glove,
gold chain, and I put a wig on,
so I've got this great hair.
- Have you created the
cartoon version yet?
- No.
- Okay,
that's the number one
thing you need to do.
- Writing that down.
- You need to immediately,
whether you hit up James,
'cause I know we have some
good illustrative capabilities,
whether you have a cousin who does it,
whether you get somebody to do it
for free at the University of Colorado,
you immediately, and I mean immediately.
start focusing on the transition of you.
- Yeah.
- You need
to build Ronald McDonald.
You're more than welcome
to be Ronald McDonald
when you go to the children's hospital,
you can be in the
commercials, but I need you
to build the cartoon
animated version immediately,
'cause it will change your life.
You will tell this story
of this exact moment
for the next 50 years of your life,
and I'm happy because it's
going to build my brand,
I'm telling you it's going to work.
- Yeah, I love it,
as soon as we get off the meeting.
- Because then what happens,
Josh, you know what happens then right?
Scale.
- Yeah.
- It's not me.
- Yeah, it's not you.
This guy is on TikTok, and Instagram,
and YouTube every day.
- Yeah.
- Then end, and I love you
occasionally showing up as if.
- Yeah.
- So again,
you could be in the commercial,
and you could be the non-profit,
and you could be, you know,
finally COVID is over like, you know,
I actually have a big idea for you,
I think you play up a whole storyline
of how you are about COVID
and how you miss people.
So that in 10 months you
have like the craziest,
fucking little like fair,
gathering, farmer's
market in your locations.
- I like that.
- You play up this whole thing
that I'm a social animal,
this fucking sucks, blah,
blah, blah, blah, blah,
and then kind of by August,
as we get into Q4 and everyone's going
to get back to normal,
you can then have permission
to say, as you know,
I've been pissed this whole time,
caught up to celebrate,
we're throwing a party,
I'll be at this location
from 9:00 to 11:00.
from 1:00 to 2:30,
and this one from 4:00 to 5:00,
but we'll have pony rides
and fucking this and that,
and it will work,
- Yeah.
- if you do local marketing.
- Yeah, and our community loves us
because one of the things,
I mean, we're deeply
involved in the community,
were on all the Facebook groups,
I mean, an example is we
had a lady who posted on,
you know, the local neighborhood group,
her son's car got keyed,
and so we picked her son's
car up, had it buffed out,
dropped it back off.
So we do stuff like that.
- And by the way Josh,
you can imagine this is why I
always advocate for mascots,
you doing that as lovely,
the character doing that is game changer.
- Yeah, love it.
Okay, that's definitely.
- You doing it as a business owner,
me doing as a business
owner, that's a nice to have,
it's a nice little sort of story,
you in full guard doing
it, and filming it,
and putting it out,
gets picked up by the local
news and becomes a thing.
- Yeah, that's actually,
that's a great point.
- Pleasure.
- Josh, this team doesn't
keep me around for my looks.
- What platforms would you
focus on as a car dealer?
- TikTok.
- Yeah, we've just kind
of dipped our toe in that.
- Let me tell you everybody
while I'm going to saying
TikTok over and over for all of you.
I mean, Vance, it's the most
important place for you,
it's free organic reach,
I don't know what else to tell you,
you post something and
80,000 people might see it.
- Yeah.
- When you have four followers
- But then how do I monetize?
How do I then turn?
'Cause obviously we can get.
- Brand.
- What's that?
Brand?
- How do you monetize
when you do a commercial?
You don't monetize
directly in the commercial,
they become aware of you
and they come to you.
- Yeah.
- Somebody sees
the fucking thing, they think it's cool,
they're 17, they tell their mom,
they want to buy it from you.
They click the fucking link on TikTok,
and you fucking sell a car.
- Yeah, love it.
- Josh, everyone's transactional,
especially car sales,
it's all fucking brand.
You intuitively are evolving,
which is why you created this character,
brilliant, I love that
you asked me that question like,
and this is what always happens,
yeah, I hear it all the time,
'cause it's a new thing,
I'm like, how do you monetize
an outdoor billboard?
Ray Catena has 8 trillion
fucking billboards.
When James and I go home,
I spoke to him years ago,
he's like, how do I monetize
this social media bullshit?
I'm like, do you think people climb up
the pole to your fucking
billboard press it and buy a car?
You're building awareness.
- Yeah.
- Oh, by the way, on the record,
TikTok is more likely for
you to be transactional
than a billboard, or radio,
and a newspaper, or TV,
because when they laugh at your video,
they click your profile,
click the URL in the profile,
and land on your website
and can go to a landing page,
like we just talked about, right,
and act with Matt, and
actually the landing page
might be a set up an appointment
if you're under 21 for deep consultation,
so you don't get fucked.
- Yeah.
- Maybe your whole spiel on TikTok
is every 21 year old and under,
you know, 16 to 20 year old gets fucked,
I'm here to protect you from
all these fucking assholes,
and like, now you're doing consultation,
like it's a fucking holes.
- That's got legs.
- Real legs.
- Yeah.
Yeah, another question for you,
and I debate about this
with our current agency
and that's SEM spend versus
just purely going OTT,
Facebook social, you know,
that sort of thing, 'cause.
- SEM is good
because it's intensive.
- It's expensive, right?
- Well, it's expensive,
and you're paying for
something a lot of times
you would have gotten anyway.
- That's what I, yeah,
and I'm competing with obviously
all the other car dealers,
but also the manufacturer to do it right.
- But you're also getting your own,
you're paying a toll booth
for your own business.
- Yeah.
- Ask your team
at your agency, how many
of the click-throughs
are directly your brand?
And they're going to tell you bullshit
that Google sells, which
is you got to play defense,
you don't want somebody else to have it,
and it's fucking horseshit.
- Yeah.
So what I've been telling them recently
is I think I just want to get out of SEM
and put all that spend, we spend,
I don't know, 40, 50
grand a month in social,
and take that 20, 30
grand I'm spending at SEM
and shifted all back to OTT social,
what do you think about that?
- When I hear that you
have such a good percentage
of social SEM, I'm excited,
I want your SEM to be
stronger so that you're just
getting intent of what you really want.
- Okay.
- Your spread
doesn't scare me, I'm
actually proud of you,
that's quite progressive.
Are you feeling good about your social?
That's a lot of money to
be spending on social.
- Yeah, I'm feeling really good about it.
- Good for you,
now, is that mainly being spent on media,
or is that spent on the creative, organic,
what does that being spent on?
- 100% media, I've got a
social media manager in house
and a videographer, so
none of that is outsourced.
- Love.
So honestly, one thing
you should think about
is once a year, this is why we built it,
I think James, again,
I don't know if it's a $15,000 whiteboard.
Yeah, exactly, James,
like Josh, once a year,
either watch my content or ping me,
and I'll answer something for
you for free for five minutes,
or James, are you still like,
25K on that thing?
- Yeah,
it depends on the number
of platforms and spend,
it's between 15 and 25.
- Even better.
Josh, if you're mainly
Facebooking and whatever,
I can promise you, 'cause we're killing
this product in Sasha, and it
doesn't have to be with us,
it could be with somebody else,
in-house teams are never
going to be as good
as the best of the best.
The 15 you spend on education,
on the current year's best practices,
you're going to spend on waste in media
when you're spending 500,000 a year,
in two seconds.
- Yeah.
- Find a solution for that.
- Okay.
- That you have to.
- James,
won't you put your contact in there?
- Josh, I can help you out.
- Okay.
- And Josh, what makes me comfortable,
and I'm pretty not transactional,
what makes me even comfortable saying that
it's what I know is that Joe,
they'll tell you not to do it,
like will tell you not to buy us
if we like listen for the
first 20 minutes and feel like,
you know, close enough.
- Yeah.
- What we found though,
is there's a big delta,
because A, we're the
best in the world at it,
and B, internal teams tend to
not be capable of keeping up
with what's going on 'cause they're not
an agency looking at everything,
looking at every business,
right?
- Yeah.
Well, my internal teams just creative,
just the vide and you
know, the organic posts,
that sort of thing, our
agency does the paid stuff.
- You should bring the paid internal.
- What's that?
You should bring the internal?
- Anytime you take media and
creative and separate them,
either with agencies
or internal, external,
you lose.
- Yeah, we're not singing the
same song sheet sometimes,
that's for sure.
- You're never are, you definitely aren't,
like you can see the blatant ones,
but if I told you the difference
of how many cars you would sell
if you had those things
aligned versus separate,
it's in the hidden troops,
you're like pumped about something
where you're getting
"leads" for 230 bucks,
and you're like pumped because
it works for your business,
but in the separation
that 230 might be 86.
- Yeah Josh, it is one of the things
that they use our mini recom for,
oftentimes they'll take
it in as a playbook,
make their hire, and then
execute against the playbook
at the mini rec.
- Josh,
I can tell you right now,
best reason you signed
up for this is knowing
that you need to take the media in house.
- Yeah.
- Promise.
Now you could have bad casting.
- For sure.
- I'm basically telling you,
you need a good quarterback
to win football games.
You could draft a bad quarterback.
- It happens.
- Yes, I'm very aware,
I'm a Jets fan.
(laughing together)
So anyway I think that.
- Or we could trade
for Deshaun Watson
- We're trying.
Cool, I'm happy with that,
let's keep it.
- Awesome.
- Rollover to Sam in Texas.
Sam let's go.
- Okay, so first Nick
gave you some great ideas
on how to create content for a market
that that feels overlooked
and mistrustful of my industry, right?
And so what I, and that's, you know,
it's a high trust thing
for us to help people,
and so it's how do we build that trust?
Nick helped quite a lot with that,
but how do I build that audience
for people to consume that content?
- I'm going to give you the
best fucking advice ever.
I'm so confident about this one,
as good as I've felt so far today,
this is the one I'm most confident about,
and I'm pretty confident
about everything else
I've said in here so far.
You have to start a podcast
and then you have to post produce
the video of the podcast for LinkedIn ads.
So what's cool about this is,
I'm going to make
assumptions that you have
a little bit of a sense of me, Sam?
What you see for me a lot of times,
I'm not an influencer, I'm
a businessman who figured
out how to do things
that could be recorded
to then be my content.
- Right.
- My entire speaking career,
which is lucrative, is mainly
because I want the content.
It's fucking crazy.
- So you get paid for something
you're going to do already?
- No, even better,
I'm getting paid for something
I wouldn't have done otherwise
that is impacting me even
more on my core business.
- Yeah.
- You know
how fucking crazy that is?
That's basically what I want you to do,
watch how this works out,
- Okay.
- so you stand up a financial service,
or a money management, or whatever,
you know, you stand up a show, you know,
dollars and cents with
Sam Rodriguez, right,
that's the show,
now that you have a podcast,
you'll be blown away
by what I'm about to say, you
start cold emailing people
on LinkedIn to be a guest
that are fancy, fancy people.
Like people that are on CNBC
and The Wall Street Journal,
and one out of every 29 of them, Sam,
is going to say yes, because
everybody is a publicity whore.
- Okay.
So how do you even get an
audience for your podcast?
How do you build that audience?
- LinkedIn.
So this is the next part.
So you film the first one with Calvin,
it's 42 minutes, now you
have to have the ability,
whether you learn this yourself,
'cause it's fun,
whether you have a younger sibling,
whether you hire an intern who, you know,
Jay, is this guy I
assume in Calvin's world,
or he definitely had somebody
in his world do this,
'cause he had six, I'm
assuming Jay handles
a lot of those things now.
But you figure out at
the lowest possible cost,
Sam, which starts with you,
do you watch 20 hours of YouTube videos
for free of how to use Adobe?
Like, you know, I'm thrilled if you want,
you know, I'm sure my team
will give you 15 minutes
for free to like how
to stand up a podcast.
Like I probably have an article
on my website right now
that explains it all.
So you start up the show,
you then have five moments
in your meeting with Calvin
that were good points,
you felt, you sounded smart,
Calvin made a good stop,
thank you, Kate, there's
something called Stork,
I'm sure Kate will tell you about that.
So, but by the way that on the record,
I know Stork is wildly
inexpensive as a newsletter,
but still you can definitely
find this stuff for free.
It might just save your time,
you might want to pay 39,
that's why people pay those
kinds of things right?
The time of finding the free,
anyway, nonetheless,
you then cut those five clips
and then you post them
with copy on your LinkedIn.
LinkedIn is the B2B version
of TikTok right now.
LinkedIn and TikTok are
the only two social media
platforms that will give you
organic reach on every post,
more than you deserve based
on your behaviors prior to the post.
Meaning if you're a "nobody",
meaning you don't even have
a TikTok or LinkedIn account,
your first post of an 39 second video
or 2 minute 19 second video,
Sam, of you and Calvin talking,
will get 3000 views.
Whereas that same video
on YouTube, and Instagram,
Facebook, and Twitter, will get nine.
- Okay.
- And that will become your life,
and then you're going to
learn how to spend ad money.
So now you learned that a video went viral
and you should spend a $1,000
against a five mile radius
of your house to get local.
Like, so da, da, da, you got it?
- Yeah.
So how do you move people
from being consumers
of your content to
consumers of your product?
- By the quality of your content.
- Okay, so they'll just.
- They will inquire,
my friend.
- I build it and they'll come?
- 100,000%, because you're going to say,
thanks everybody for listening,
Sam Rodriguez and you know,
send an email to me if you need me,
say I'm at the desk,
and things will just start happening.
In the first episode
you can say, here I am,
I don't know if you guys know
this character on the internet, Gary Vee,
told me to do podcasts,
well, here I am,
let me tell you about myself,
I grew up here, I did,
this is what I do for a living,
does this, you know,
my ambition is to educate,
you put some karma on the board,
feature some guests that I
think deserve recognition,
let the chips fall where they may.
Would I love to be your person?
Sure, I would not even say
that line or say that line,
they both work, then end.
- So if I want, if I'm trying to build,
say a nationwide team
of advisors that do
fantastic work for people,
how do I get these people
that are consuming me
to want to work with my team versus me?
- Very, very easily,
you speak to it about day one,
like I don't sell myself at VaynerMedia,
I mean, you just, you say it,
you storytell, you have your
team on one of the episodes
and everyone shoots the shit.
- Okay.
- You just tell people
the truth.
You know, let me, I'm going to role-play.
Hey guys, first of all,
thanks everybody who's listening,
this is now episode 19,
this has been insane,
like I told you, Gary Vee,
when he told me to do this
I never thought I'd have this
many people already listening,
I'm blown away, a couple of
things I just want to share,
a lot of you reaching out to work with me,
let me tell you a little bit
more about my actual business.
I've got a group of nationwide people,
I vet them, I do this,
so mostly the reaching out, like,
honestly, I'm probably not
going to work directly with you,
you're going to be working with my team.
By the way, if you're out there listening
and you think you're great at this,
I'd love to have you on my team.
So if you email me and say, you
want to be part of the team,
I'm also always looking for that.
And also, by the way, if not,
you know, please sit back and
enjoy this free information,
and I hope it brings you value,
or maybe brings an important
question that you can bring
to your financial advisor.
And I think what's cool about that, Sam,
is you've already been in this meeting
with me now for 40 minutes,
you can see my concern.
We have things that I think can help Josh,
but I don't necessarily want
to sell Josh the $15,000 thing either.
Like, I don't want to be transactional,
I want to educate of like, hey,
here's what you need
to think about, right?
In the macro, the right thing is
for me to get everybody's media business,
but that's how we really do business,
but I'm not telling Josh
to hire Sasha over who
the fuck he's using.
I'm fucking telling him the best advice,
which is take this shit in house.
- Yeah.
- Got it?
- Yip, yeah, perfect, thanks.
- Do that, cheers.
- Awesome.
- Let's keep it moving.
- Would you want to be on a podcast?
- I will be your 55th episode
guests if you get there.
- 55, it's getting
written down everywhere.
- 55, love it.
Joe Q keep me honest on that.
- Let's go, I'll keep you honest for sure,
let's go on up to Brad in Oklahoma
and talk about agency life.
- Oh, hey Gary,
so I mentioned that we work mostly
with home service companies you know,
plumbers, HVAC contractors,
so I've got kinda like
a two-part question,
what do you think the most
underutilized platforms
are for contractor marketing?
And then part two is what
do we need to do right
now to make sure they stay relevant in,
you know, three to five years?
- I think the most underused
platform is LinkedIn,
because I think LinkedIn is acting more
like Facebook did five to seven years ago,
not only are you getting organic reach,
people are open to all kinds
of information on LinkedIn.
This is not just about, you know,
like for example, I'm actually
making a note right now,
this has been in the
back of my mind forever,
I have a great kid on my team,
Sam Doyle, at my dad's liquor store,
give me one second, I'm sorry,
but I'm being mellow right now,
Sam to make three minute
wine videos for LinkedIn
for wine text daily.
Anyway, boom,
like I know he's going to post something
about wine and that's going to
lead to signups organically.
So LinkedIn, for sure, Brad,
by a country mile, it
will lead to business,
it's got an ad product
where you can target people
by location, 'cause most of
these businesses are local.
It's expensive ads,
but it's very relevant.
Like the people see 'em, which matters,
you know people are like, well, Gary,
I can buy these ads for $3 CPMs,
I'm like, nobody's seeing them.
They're banner ads on
home.com, who gives a fuck?
- True.
- Right?
So relevance is completely, Brad,
based on content.
You could get me to stop
right now if it was titled
how to build your own
home office during COVID
content, right?
The reason I exist, some
of you have followed
me for a long time, Calvin,
I know that to be true,
I'm very consistent,
for 12 years I've been
saying the same shit,
the reason I'm worth listening to
is I make it all relevant to the moment.
My attention arbitrage, content media,
humanity way to manage is consistent.
My strategies around
TikTok versus LinkedIn
evolve on a day-to-day basis.
The slang, the creative,
the ideas I use evolve every day,
that's valuable.
Back to Brad using it,
my religion is locked in,
my day-to-day practicing of it evolves
with the reality of the situation.
- Yeah.
- Content is the answer
to everything.
- Alright.
- Yesterday
we all had a day off
because of the words that man said.
Seriously think about that,
everybody in our country
stayed home yesterday,
didn't work for the most part,
because a marvelous man came along,
but many marvelous men
and women have thought what MLK thought,
it was his ability to create
content that enabled that.
So if you're not putting
in the reps on content,
you're basically, it doesn't
matter what your strategy is.
Here's my strategy, I'd
like to get a six pack,
here's the strategy of how to do that,
I need to eat way leaner
and I need to do a lot more ab exercises.
Good news, I have an incredible
strategy to get a six pack.
Now what?
You gotta do it.
I'm telling you the answers right now,
it's TikTok and LinkedIn.
The question is, are you
going to put in the reps?
- Cool.
- Awesome.
- Thanks.
- You got it, brother.
- Cool, motoring along,
let's go up to Chicago, Vance,
let's talk to Gary Vee.
- Gary Vee, so of course,
you know that you're the god of posting,
I just want you to hear it from me.
Yeah, a couple of things,
I want to talk to you in a like interview
type of consultant type of style.
First off, let me say that
I know that your grandfathers are proud
of the businessman that you
have become, both of them.
- Thank you for saying that.
- I admire the way you
wear your no belt style,
it's dope.
(laughing together)
And I think something that is very,
very important is I seen a
video with our personal trainer
Jordan Syatt, he says,
that you'd like to work
out every day, man.
(laughing together)
He said, every day I take a break,
'cause you had to work out every day.
So that's somewhat of
what I wanted to share,
so I wrote the book about you,
it's called how Gary
Vee changed the world.
- Thank you.
- It's dope
because you have the world,
and then like for as like
the States and stuff,
or the continent, you got happiness,
you got brands, you got patients,
you got all the good stuff.
- Thank you sir.
- And it's hard cover.
- Love it.
- I was trying to get in touch with you,
I seen that you had an
event on December the 9th
that got canceled,
and before I found 4Ds,
I bought a ticket to come
to New York to go to the pizza place
that your part owners in,
- Yes.
- And I was gonna buy a lot of pies,
and I was gonna try to
get them to call you.
So I want to go, yeah,
I want to go on the offense with you, man.
I want to help you buy the Jets,
you know, that's my goal.
- Thank you.
- So,
- Vance,
as we go through that journey,
I assume based on the
things you brought up,
being a paid author where you're
not self publishing like that,
being a speaker that gets 5,
10, 15, 20, 25, 30, 40,000 a gig,
those are probably the two
things that you're most looking
at in front of you.
- Yeah, exactly.
Where are you in speaking?
Have you, you know, as
I know this game well,
it takes a long time before
people get paid to speak.
Have you had paid
speaking engagements yet?
- No, I host my own events.
So yeah, just five of them.
- Okay, got it.
- But since COVID, you know,
I can't, but that's
- I totally get it.
- what I'll do.
- Vance, it's interesting,
Josh asked a question and it's
come up one other time here,
let me give you the number one mistake
that I see every day of the week,
which is people in personal brand
try to transact way too soon.
And then the audience fights them off
and they have no interest. (hiccups)
So the thing that you need to figure
out is what do you have
to say to the world?
And how are you putting
out content on a daily
basis across all platforms?
That is your number one requirement.
And with no mention of
buy tickets to my events,
no mention to buying books, no mention,
build community.
- Right.
- People will come out to you and say,
hey, I see that you have this community,
can you do this for me?
Can you do that for me?
You can monetize the B2B,
try not to monetize the audience
for one year and put out as
much content as possible.
It is the most important
thing I can tell you.
- Okay, so my ask is a
little bit deeper than that,
so like I said, I wanna
help you buy the Jets,
I'm going to give you a
hundred million dollars
towards buying the Jets,
but I just need one thing from you,
what I would like to ask you is to,
will you have an interview to bring me
with you on an interview, I don't know,
if we're going to be going back, dude,
are your next events,
are they going to happen,
or do you think they're
going to be postponed?
- Right now my team is planning
for me to be in person
for starting in September.
- Okay, so that's like the
UK or something like that,
I believe?
- That might
just be randomly booked there,
but like, like Chicago, like Texas,
like anywhere is what we're planning.
Obviously none of us on
this call have a clue
about what COVID's
evolution's going to be.
- Okay, so I would like you to,
I want to help you buy the Jets,
but I just need one solid from
you, I only need one thing,
and I would like you to bring me with you
when you do an interview,
and I want to be right there with you,
I want to be right there
with you, an interview,
and I only want to say 11 words.
I want to say this is a good man,
I wrote a book about him,
make sure you keep listening to him,
and my name is Chicago
Motivation, 11 words,
that's all I want to say
for 10 events though,
for 10 interviews.
Yeah, I got my own coffee.
(laughing together)
- You started with one,
what's going on here, you know,
listen that opening.
- That's one thing,
but it's just 10 times.
- I understand
what you're saying.
- Yeah. (laughs)
- Why don't we start with one,
and let me see how I feel about it.
Obviously you're opening acting me,
you're trying to get
awareness through my audience,
I understand what you're doing.
What I'm trying to think through Vance
is how do I bring you more value?
My intuition is I have a couple of ideas
with my 1:37 PM, I've
got a couple of ideas
that will get you what
you're actually looking for.
- Okay.
- But for example,
I may have you ask me
a couple of questions
and reply to one and
split-screen it on my Instagram
and tag you, and that
will give you 10 times
the awareness of what you would be doing
by physically going to 10
events and saying that on stage.
So let me think,
- Okay.
- I'm going to stay in touch with Joe,
I'm going to tag you into my team
and we'll come up with something,
we'll give you a little
bit of love somehow.
- Okay, cool,
a couple more things,
- Okay.
- so I got a couple questions,
so do you know how to use Photoshop,
I wanted to ask you that.
- Absolutely not.
- You don't,
and one thing that I really liked
that you said in one of
your videos is you said
that a person can post content every day
and it can never be tiring,
- Correct.
- but you said sometimes a
person could post one word
and it's too much because
they don't have good intent.
So I thought that was very important.
You know, so I'm gonna leave
it at that.
- And Vance, I love that,
so let me tell you this,
I'm telling you think, 'cause I know you,
what I mean by that is I've been around,
I'm an old man now I got a
lot of wisdom for 45 years.
All of this, it's been a theme here today,
the person that can hold
their breath the longest wins.
And so what I would tell
you is I'm really interested
by you and I wanna help
you, I'll tell you why.
In one breath, you so get what
I said in that content thing,
you got it.
- Yeah.
- On the flip side, and I get it,
you get to the moment right now,
here we are, right,
you're going to fucking
fly, you buy pizza,
like here we are, and so in your mind,
rightfully so, you're like
I'm going to take my shot,
right, but the balancing
act is on the other side,
you know, while you were talking,
like, do I really want to let this dude
get that one time to do that?
Because everybody wants
that, I don't know him,
you know, in general,
I'm concerned about motivational people,
'cause they feel like they're just trying
to monetize the audience
and not bring value,
so I'm going through all
this stuff in my head, right,
but I'm leaning towards
intuition and giving a gift,
and I'm like, I'm going fucking do,
literally this is what happened, man,
I'm not kidding, I'm just telling you.
And I'm like, fuck it,
I'm going to do this,
and then you said 10 times,
and that basically is that one word.
I'm like this fucking guy.
- But I wanna help you
buy the Jets though. (laughs)
- No, I'm gonna buy the jets,
I don't need your help, you
want me to give you a co-sign
to my audience to spark your career,
which by the way is right.
- Right.
- You know, there's nothing
you saying on stage, I'm a good man
and getting to my audience
that's doing anything
for me to buy the Jets.
I'm coming out of my goodness
of my heart to give you exposure, so.
- Yeah, it's gonna help me,
but in return, I'm
going to have businesses
and different things going on,
and what I'm going to
come with money as a man.
You know what I'm saying?
- I appreciate that.
Good news, I already have enough money
from people to buy the Jets.
- Okay.
- That to me is not the issue,
the issue and the value I want to bring
in this meeting is I think
you're in an interesting spot
where I think I can really
help, which excites me.
You're not gonna need Gary
Vee, or any of these books,
or services, and the
motivational speakers of the past
if you hear me and realize by you honestly
with good intent, putting
out content every day
on just LinkedIn and TikTok,
that you'll have the leverage, not me,
that's what I'm trying to get you to.
Don't let me be the
gatekeeper to your spring pad,
you be the fucking person.
- No, I'm not letting
you be the gatekeeper,
I'm saying it's a lot
of motivational speakers
that have come and like
Tony Robbins, Les Brown,
all those guys, and you the man right now,
you know what I'm saying?
And I'm next, I'm next for real,
I'm not joking.
You know what I mean?
Like, I'm next, so.
(inaudible)
- I'm humble, let me promise you,
I'm telling you with my
soul because I love you,
I want you to be next,
and the number one way you get to be next
is by putting out content every day,
specifically on those two platforms,
I'm being dead serious with you.
- Okay, cool,
but we'll still do that co-sign,
I'm going to figure out how
to do it for you one time.
- I appreciate it.
- You got it.
Alright, who's next?
You're on mute.
- Rookie mistake, Calvin in Brooklyn,
you are next,
and we're going to have
a Brooklyn Manhattan show
to close us out in Gary's time.
- What's up Gary?
- Good and you Cal,
- So great to see you again, man.
- Great to see you.
- Yes,
so my question is around,
I have my Simplero,
which is my software company, Simplero,
right now, like I said, we basically
had no marketing team for
either the software or anything.
We've just grown through word of mouth,
by having a great product, and
doing great customer service.
I've tried in the past,
we had the team Calvin,
I've had other people
on the marketing team,
It didn't quite work out.
So it's a reset.
- Give me one minute on the learnings
of why it did not work
out or the hypothesis,
'cause maybe you don't know yet?
- Yeah, the hypothesis is,
I hired people, I think just
not the right people, honestly,
and lack of leadership and
clear strategy from my side,
but like I hired people,
nobody thought to ask,
like, who is our avatar?
Who is our target market?
Or like, you know, basic
things of that nature,
and I didn't think of it either.
- Right.
- And last year
on team Calvin,
was like a lot of just
bringing a lot of people on,
a lot of chaos and you know, I like chaos,
but it didn't work out with the team.
- I understand.
- Yeah,
and so trying to figure out like,
what I love doing is a live
Q&A's, I freaking love it.
- Me too.
- Bringing people on,
just answering the questions,
helping them with whatever,
I enjoy it so much,
I don't need to like make it transactional
or anything like that.
So we've been doing some
of that and it's great,
we're not getting a lot of traction
on people actually viewing the content.
So to try to figure out like,
do I just do that branding, like you said,
for a year and put all that content
and not even think about monetizing it.
- Where are you distributing the content?
- We've been doing YouTube, Facebook,
Instagram, Twitter to some extent,
not LinkedIn and not TikTok.
So that's.
- Perfect, that excites me.
Exactly.
- We're starting.
- That excites me,
I'm sure Jay's pretty head,
and so you'll attack that.
So to me, the answer is yes,
but what you can imagine
will make both of you
far more excited is actually
seeing you're getting traction,
hence strategic, organic content.
Everything's right, this
is why I'm so loud, y'all,
the reason I'm yelling so
loud is these doors close.
Facebook fan pages were insanity in 2012,
Twitter was bonkers in 2009, 10, 11.
I maxed a million followers
as a liquor store guy
in New Jersey, right?
Instagram was crazy in 2014, 15.
TikTok was crazier a year ago
than it is today, already.
Get on LinkedIn and TikTok
organically yesterday.
But understand that
the content, the slang,
the written words, the way you do it,
it will do better if you
understand the platforms.
You know, when when Sam add six hashtags
that are financial terms
to his little clip,
that may make 10 more people discover it.
You know, when you lean on Jay,
'cause he actually is native to TikTok,
'cause he and or his
social circle lives in it,
he's gonna know how to
do the sticker overlays
or what a duet is, that shit matters.
Strategic organic content.
- Yeah.
So in terms, it feels it feels
to me like the SAS business,
a software company, there's
like a lot of practice
around how map and market SAS,
and sort of more direct
response type of things,
and you know, the CAC and the LTVs,
and all like all of those
kinds of that side of things,
and then there's the content
brand stuff.
- You got it.
That's why I won with empathy,
a pure math and art machine,
by the way, if there was
only the content part,
I would have never built VaynerMedia.
I want to build the greatest math and art,
CAC and LTV machine in the world.
And then you put, you know,
so think of it like I want to build
the best batter to make the best cupcake,
I'll be the whipped cream,
the cherry, and the sprinkles,
that's what makes the
ultimate club cupcake.
But if you don't have the cupcake part,
then you know what ends up happening?
People just are sizzle and they lose.
- Got it, yes.
- Now, what I've really
learned in my 3.0 version
is I'm almost turning the sizzle
into a smart CAC and LTV thing,
which is the hens team Gary,
and that's why we're now at this apex.
- Say more about that?
- I used to just make good videos
on YouTube and I was crushing right?
Now I know how to take that video
and create 31 pieces
of creative out of it,
it's a podcast, it's
an article for my blog,
it's a LinkedIn post,
one clip gets 14 million views from,
that's why DailyVee started, right?
It's why I started vlogging my life,
I'm like, oh my God,
this is the fucking powder,
so I'm pushing Sam,
who's busy doing another
thing, to do a podcast,
that will be the powder to make
all the other stuff happen.
It's why I'm so pumped with you,
I think QA is the number one way
to make great post creative content.
'Cause you don't have to
think, you're just answering,
and then you and Jay,
and whoever else are then
tweaking, and you know?
- Yeah, it's.
- You can take it one
step further, Gary,
by now applying it to your business,
where you could take a tweet
and make a Super Bowl
commercial later down the road.
- Yeah, I mean, to your point the PCS,
the post creative strategists,
the person, Calvin,
you'll eventually add to
your team that you and Jay,
and whoever you're making 39 pieces
of content a week, or a day,
and then somebody reading every comment
from that to then inform the
next thing you should do.
And to James's point at VaynerMedia,
we've gotten to a place where
a single tweet eventually
became the seed that
created a Super Bowl spot.
- Right, yeah, fantastic.
And so is there a way to like,
how do I best leverage my software company
into the personal brand?
Like I'm using that audience for Q&A,
and using it for distribution, right,
is there another way there?
And then the next question is, you know,
leveraging the personal brand into some
of the other products that I have,
like that my body meal
meal replacement thing,
and things of that nature.
- So I think you're doing
the right thing with the business end,
as far as your other
things, that's where Jay
has do strategic organic content,
AKA, all your bios have to be strategic,
right, so your URL for one
week on your biggest platform,
let's make pretend for now it's Instagram,
has a URL that links
out to the SAS company.
But wait a minute, then you're like,
wait a minute, that makes no sense,
the Instagram audience
is much better for meals,
so we're going to put our meal thing.
Oh, we're converting better there, right?
Instagram story swipe ups, right?
You know, and so you're
cross-pollinating it,
and I mean, I always tell people,
before you come to this,
before you work with Sasha or Vayner,
audit the shit out of me.
Why do I have different
URLs on all my social media?
You think I'm doing that for my health?
I promise you I'm not.
You know, why do I do this?
Why do I do that?
So keep that in mind as well.
But it's pointing people
to different places based
on different places you have attention.
- Got it.
And what's your split between
so the organic LinkedIn, TikTok,
I get that, but where
does the paid come in
on the brand side of things?
- It depends on the business, but TikTok,
Instagram, and Facebook are
my favorite paid products.
- Right.
- That's why.
- So are they as well, are
they just based on like,
is that just awareness impressions,
or do you track that
to some other metrics?
- One more time my brother?
'Cause I was applying to Jay saying
that he copied my bio and I was laughing,
one more time?
- Sorry, yeah.
So when you do paid
around the brand stuff,
do you just do that based on, you know,
to get impressions, awareness?
- Yes, it's my general fee,
straight up my feel.
Do I think people are seeing this
and now they know who
Gary Veeaynerchuk is?
And I usually pay against
either one of two things,
something that went organically viral,
I'm like, oh, people like this,
let's pay, or something I
really want fuckers to know,
nothing in the middle.
- I've never seen any,
I see all your organic
content all this time,
I never see any of your.
- I'm spending more and more
money on people on my team
because I'm so good at organic,
but I'm not against paying,
and I'm about to spend a lot of money
on TikTok because it's so cheap.
- Got it, nice.
Oh, alright,
if I have more time,
I have a much quite
different question here.
So I realized that there's a lot of people
that I know that I could reach out to
and do like do like clubhouse panels with
or things of that nature, or other things,
and I just know this like insecurity
that pops up in me all the time,
I'm like, I don't belong,
they don't want to hang out with me,
they don't wanna play with
me and that kind of stuff.
And I don't know
if you have something that
you can just say to that.
- Do you remember riding a bike,
swimming, or kissing somebody
for the first time?
- Yes I do.
- Or having sex?
Like anything that all
of us have been through
this multiple times, growing
up had scary ass shit,
like it was petrified, I was petrified
to swim and ride a bike.
I was petrified to kiss a girl.
- Actually at the same time,
that doesn't sound so scary.
- So like, I understand being scared,
I just want to remind everybody,
you eventually did it,
and now it sounds ridiculous
of the thought of being scared of it.
What's going to happen?
They're going to make you feel bad
that you're not important enough?
What, you're gonna reach out to Gary Vee
and he's not gonna reply
and now you think, fuck,
he doesn't think I'm cool?
Like, who gives a shit?
Go to the next person.
- Yeah, no, you're right.
- 100%.
Have Jay do it, right?
And I'm like, and by the way,
that's what you do.
Like I have notice how I
said I don't do Photoshop,
I pay people to do Photoshop.
I don't like it, I don't how to do it.
Alright, I have a little bit of emergency,
I have to bounce.
We're good, Joe?
- Yeah, we're good, we went
through everybody twice.
Thanks Gary.
- Cheers,
bye everyone.
- Thanks Gary.
- Enjoy the rest of this,
take care.
YouTube watching, what's up,
it's Gary Vee.
First of all, thank you so much,
I hope you're doing super
well during these times.
I also want to ask you
please subscribe because my
commitment and exploration
of YouTube is about to explode, stories,
polls, more content, more engagement,
more surprise, and delight.
This is the time to subscribe.
I hope you consider it,
and I hope I see you soon.